where will Kirk Cousins be two years  from today teaching gym class I like her  cousins he ain't going to be in  Minnesota no he will not be again where  will Kirk Cousins be two years from  today working at Kohl's uh calls  uh actually working for an insurance  company I can see him doing that  uh retired it's great you can fit him  dad not with the Vikings Dallas Cowboys  on a different team uh Ghost Rider in  the minivan  [Music]  I think he will  not be playing for the Vikings  uh working at a car wash wherever Jesus  wants him to be Kohl's cash for real  yeah his mom's house  Minnesota's all-time great quarterback  reluctantly he's probably gonna sign  another 84 million contract with the  bikes  so he's probably on the bike no that  means you want a divisional [ __ ] NFC  fight  let's go